- Well, you know, staying
on a tractor for a long time
did not prepare you for being
in the desert for a long time
because I did see you post something
that I thought was awesome.
Watch this.
- It is 105 degrees outside.
I got the air conditioner
on and I'm still hot.
Like the back of my neck is hot.
I don't even know where that come from.
Now, I'm coming up on a ridge.
If I get over this damn ridge,
best not be no more damn desert.
How the desert this damn big?
(audience applauding)
(Kelly laughing)
- Yes!
- So, I don't even think
I have to ask you where
you're driving because I've driven
from Texas to California many a times.
And there is a stretch-
is that where you were kind of coming
from, Arkansas to California?
- Yeah, it was Flagstaff to California.
- Oh my God.
And there's, if you don't
stop, there's one thing.
If you don't stop for gas-
- Yeah, I stopped for, well,
I have a really cool hybrid car.
So I only stopped for gas three times.
- Oh, that's awesome.
Yeah.
- But I only, but yeah, I stopped for gas,
like in the desert and that's
like, after that video,
I was like,
it is so hot out here.
- Yeah.
- What is going on?
But I was driving to,
I drove from Arkansas.
I picked up the car in Arkansas
and I drove from Arkansas
to Los Angeles and I was
driving out here to do the show,
do Grand Crew.
- Oh my gosh.
That's so awesome.
(audience clapping)
That's so very cool.
So did you swear off road trips
from road rules, were you just like done?
- I like to get naked in a hot tub.
Don't worry about it, Justin.
(Kelly laughing)
Do you say naked?
- I say naked.
- Oh.
- See, I think that sounds more hillbilly.
- If you use it in a sentence,
"I came in and he was naked."
That's kind of country.
That's, yeah, you're right.
- Exactly.
Exactly.
(audience clapping)
- You right.
- I was like, that one
sounds more country to me.
You were like, you know what, nevermind.